PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Welcome
back to "Get Cooking
in Cloud," where we
share the best recipes
to apply in your cloud kitchen.
I'm Priyanka, and
today is our final day
in our gluten-free kitchen
with our special guest, Jenny.
JENNY BROWN: That's right.
We've been through so
much on this journey,
from realizing it was
more than just a recipe
to making sure allergens
and personally identifiable
information stay
where they belong.
So let's jump back in.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: In
the last two episodes,
we've talked about
Dinner Winner, which
is an application that
collects recipes from users
all over the world,
and the winning recipe
makes it on their platform
and receives an award.
We know there might be personal
information initially tied
to these submissions that need
to be removed before anything
else can happen.
And we want this to be a
seamless automated process.
We saw an architecture of how
they can automate and classify
the uploaded data by using Cloud
Storage, Cloud Functions, DLP,
and pub/sub.
JENNY BROWN: We created
a four-step process
for the Dinner Winner team to
get this solution implemented.
And we were halfway
there by setting up
our project and our permissions
and creating the Google Cloud
Storage bucket and pub/sub.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Today,
we combine the remaining
ingredients and bake.
JENNY BROWN: When making
something gluten-free,
we need to check on two things--
our ingredients are
gluten-free and our environment
is gluten-free.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
Similarly for Dinner Winner,
we need two Cloud
Functions-- one
that is invoked when an object
is uploaded to Google Cloud
Storage and the
other that is invoked
when a message is received
in the Cloud pub/sub queue.
Let's start by creating the
Cloud Function that triggers
from the Cloud Storage bucket.
We will open Cloud Functions
and create a new function.
Name it as Create_DLP_job.
In the trigger field, we
will select Cloud Storage
and select the quarantine
bucket from the bucket browser.
Select Python 3.7
for the runtime.
And in the inline
editor, copy and paste
the code from the link
in the description
below in main.py and
requirements.txt.
You will find that there is a
Create_DLP_job function, which
creates the DLP job
from when a recipe is
uploaded in the bucket.
So in the function
to execute, we
will replace the hello_GCS
with Create_DLP_job
and create that function.
JENNY BROWN: Now, we need to
create the Cloud Function that
gets invoked when a message is
received in the Cloud pub/sub
queue.
It's pretty much the
same, but this time, we'll
choose Cloud pub/sub
in the trigger field
and enter our pub/sub topic.
We will use the same
function code as last time,
but in the function to execute,
we use resolve_DLP this time.
And with that, we have both
our Cloud Functions ready.
And now for the moment of truth.
Has our recipe for secure
application automation
done the trick
for Dinner Winner?
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: I
think we've effectively
avoided any personal
information cross-contamination,
but we will need to test
it out and make sure.
JENNY BROWN: So we've got
some sample recipes that
have some sensitive
data in them and some
that have non-sensitive data.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: We are
defining the sensitive data
as name, email address,
location, and phone numbers,
but you can change
it in the code
to define it values or
info types that you prefer.
JENNY BROWN: OK,
so let's test it.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: We
will do it in Cloud Shell.
Clone the git repo,
navigate to the sample data,
and then copy the files over
to GCS quarantine bucket.
The DLP API inspects
and classifies
each file uploaded to
the quarantine bucket
and moves it to the
appropriate target bucket based
on its classification.
JENNY BROWN: Let's
open our buckets
and review the uploaded files.
Let's click on the quarantine
bucket and click on a file
and see that it does not
have any sensitive data.
Let's also check
out one of the files
from the non-sensitive bucket.
And we see that it does not
contain any sensitive data
either.
Now, one final check.
Let's see one of the files
in our sensitive bucket.
And as expected,
this contains emails,
which is one of our
sensitive data parameters
that we had set.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: So that's it.
Dinner Winner has their
application automated
and can return to their
gamified recipe submission
with confidence.
JENNY BROWN: Here's to the
pursuit of deliciousness.
Check out the article linked
in the description for more
step-by-step information.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: If
you're hungry for more,
be sure to like, subscribe,
and catch us next time
for another episode of
"Get Cooking in Cloud."